good morning uh this is the subcommittee
here work session on the
senate bill 383
relative to land surveying services
we have three members of our
subcommittee here which is a quorum of
the subcommittee
we were expecting at least one more was
not yet present uh representative goalie
whose wisdom we trust is sitting in
um
the uh let if i may start um
having looked at this bill
i saw
with
some problems with the new section that
have some real problems with it maybe
render it unworkable
and
the first
thing that i noticed
was the civil penalty is done
uh adjudicated by the board
which acts both as the judge and the
jury you have a hearing before the board
but it's
uh
they are the they're comprised of less
of of land surveyors
the um
there is no
appeal to the to superior court which is
a typical language for some of these
things
um
condom demetraki said that
part of his
motivation was to reduce clogging of the
courts
and
even if this
even if this is found
someone is convicted or do
whatever the word we want to use here
found by the board in violation buying
ten thousand dollars you now have a
piece of paper
you're still going to have to go to
court
you may think you may have a summary
judgment or something fast maybe i don't
i want to step back because i'm actually
into the bill
but i i want to repeat some headlines
that i've mentioned
um
despite
my
what i'm offering here is my opinion and
my criticism i want something good to
come out of this i don't know that it
can happen with this but i'll tell you
the direction i think we want to go and
i want to i'm obviously going to listen
to this
subcommittee and
invite uh representative goalie to
um
representative ryan is here great great
okay
okay all right uh
representative brian i'm just intro i
introduced open the session we're
starting i'm uh i started to talk about
specifics of the bill
uh before i invite the subcommittee to
chime in
give their opinions i
then interrupted myself to say that i
want i think all of us want to see
something good come out of this we these
people have a legitimate gripe we want
to see that addressed
but a good idea is not necessarily a
good bill
and that's kind of the direction i'm
the
so we're we talked about the uh
now the idea of this ten thousand i
wondered where this came from and we
inadvertently did some research
yesterday after one of the hearings and
found that the medical society has a
similar provision fifty thousand
medicines
i'm
bored
of course of course the course the
board of medicine
i don't know that any this has ever been
done
and i have a
i don't know that i would support that
some of the older boards seem to have
this i don't think it's a good idea
pro and maybe that's why it's never been
actually implemented because
if you if somebody's practicing medicine
or practicing land surveying and it's
just a civilian
how does a board have the judicial
authority to go after somebody walking
down the street who's committed a crime
you go that's what the
the attorney general
that's what the courts are for you puni
you you're
licensed land surveyors are going to be
looking to licensure
suspending or revoking a license
uh part of what i also wanted to say is
there is no
there's no magic we can improve the
situation but
i don't know that there's anything we
can really
we can't get perfection we can't
you you misbehaved we're locking you up
the patrol's car is coming you're not
getting out of jail i mean that's just
not going to happen
the
we have to go through due process uh
which
this sort of
um
what was my concern about the
judge and jury aspect of that again
other boards were doing it but i don't
support that i'm not going to man the
ramparts to undo that but i would have
never supported and speak against it as
the
i mentioned that it would be nice to
have whatever the solution uh to get
something about superior court but
probably the most
more important or the most important
thing in my view is
the person
that's been hurt
is not indemnified he's not mentioned in
here
and i want to see
and i wait for the subcommittee to chime
in
i want to see the person who has been
injured
made
at least whole maybe more than all
legal expenses
whatever's need is needed to right the
wrong
now if we can
when i said we can't make it perfect but
we can improve
i would seek legal advice
ols maybe can provide it
can we with legislation make it easier
for you to pursue to get a judgment
against
someone who practices without a license
uh
expired license whatever
can we help as with the legislature to
do that for you
but i don't
uh so there i am
i think i would like to i know i don't
think i would like
personally to see
indemnification of the injured party
a more realistic
you might for something like this we
just accepted the words guilty of a
class b misdemeanor i have no reason to
this is not driving without a driving
without a license that's a class b or
it's a violation or something this is a
this is a real injury and i don't know
why it shouldn't be an a if you want to
change something that would be the first
thing that i would look at
make this an a was the possibility of uh
jail to
uh a has a
criminal penalty of two thousand dollars
and up to a year in in uh county jail
um
so
which is significant because b has no
oh that's a fine
judge going to continue it it's
for that matter
anyway
i am interested in making this the
situation better i don't think we can do
this in time or
to rescue this particular bill but i'm
declaring i'm almost finished by the way
my openness to improve this i i know a
rivaling representative from dover here
uh and i'm done um the other thing is
the we have no pro
from what i've determined we have no
problem with the non-resident licensure
that should really probably go into
we're just talking a moment ago into a
69 and there's a roman one and make the
present roman one a and this roman uh b
of um a 69
roman one yes mr chair i would i would
like to put it because there's already
section 310 a69 which is on non-resident
licenses for land surveyors and i would
just like to put this in
your wording in there under roman one
which is the board may on application
and payment of the fee issue a license
of the lands or payer to any person of
any state
etc provide the applicant is registered
or licensed
in where in the state where the
requirements are equal to or greater
than the requirements of this state
so this would simply replace that
well actually it would
add the option of meeting the
requirements for licensure
in
a 63 roman 1 and 2 which are the
requirements for a resident
so this would just allow a non-resident
to apply for license either as a
licensed surveyor in another state or by
meeting the requirements for licensure
in new hampshire
would meet the meet your desire and our
desire to license more people
appropriately without adding another new
section to our already fat law books yes
represent
that
again
yes
right that's why we would revise it to
your the language from senate bill 277
which says or
i'm taking your language from 277 which
says or
first section the violations and
penalties
i also disagree with making the board
the prosecutor and the judge for
unlicensed practice
i i would suggest that that instead of
trying to fix
that process which is
not our field of expertise
we simply say
take take the roman 3 the board may
investigate
actual alleged or suspected unlicensed
activity
and shall support the
the prosecution of such
i mean that's what you really want you
want the attorney general to pay
attention to the surveyors and if you
present the case you know this person
did such and such
and we have the expert witnesses to call
on
that will help them to take the cases
i also think we should recommend that
the
registry of deeds
and the planning boards
not accept
anything that is not from a licensed
surveyor
which
i don't think we can tack onto this
spill but it's something that we really
ought to consider for next year
um
how do you feel about the
well madam chair what's going to say on
that
i think every plan that comes into the
zoning board comes in with a stamp and i
think that's what the problem is they
are being stamped
but the clerks may not be looking at the
particular stamp to see if they are
licensed and
so you know it's easy to see that it's
not stamped the question is is it a
legitimate stamp
right and
my husband was on the planning board
said he didn't know about the town and
city acceptance but he was pretty sure
the registry of deeds did check things
like that so that's at least
one way to prevent recording an
incorrect map but
i don't think that's
germaine to this bill and we don't have
but it but it's a good idea for next
year
well no we're please to make an
amendment
we will amend it i mean it's not interim
study
there's some things we got to get
through
i i really think we ought to push the
non-resident licensure through because
that's important
uh in my opinion there's no reason we
can't put what you just said too about
the board may investigate any actual or
suspected licensed activity and
recommend prosecution to the attorney
general and report the same to the
attorney general
so that's
an improvement not that i might also
vote for making
while we're doing
tinkering in a good direction
yeah
i think there can be a lot of money
yeah this you should not be this is i
can recognize from other legislation how
people just put boilerplate here but
this has to be examined on its own and
uh
so these are the improvements but i'm
i'm still interested if we're talking
about
something coming in next year
indemnification of the injured party
well that's
i think that's one reason to send it
for prosecution is that there
they can deal with indemnification and
and the uh
can they i don't know i suppose no
that's why i think we need some legal we
need some legal advice on it because i'm
i'm really hot about that what's what
difference does it make when
we
find this guy if the guy that's got the
house in the wrong place or
he's still thanks thanks what about me
but for me
uh the ten thousand dollars
i don't know where that comes from
it comes from the guilty
oh oh where are you meaning the bill or
in the bill no that came from heaven
that's directly copied from the board of
medicine statute is my guess no there
but i don't think any of this has ever
been collected that's is my point i
think you put a million who cares
representative brian
well
it's not your main tour but it is along
the same lines
indirectly when we had like in the city
somebody pulling a false alarm when i
was on the fire department they had to
come up
with a fine
and they determined what would be the
block of time that it took and they came
up with that dollar amount now whether
that person ever was charged with that
because most were juveniles or something
like that but maybe they didn't pay the
full amount but it gave the court the
authority
to enforce that so
my question also would be the ten
thousand dollars is that up to ten
thousand dollars could the court look at
it and say
that you know will levy two thousand
so it's so it's the high end not to
exceed so it puts the cap so somebody
may only get a thousand
excuse me a thousand dollar fine out of
this well that that's fine but what i do
what needs to be
a fine-tuned is you can't i'm just not
in favor what i don't care if it's a
dollar of the price of the board being
both the prosecutor and
the jury determining what it should be
there's got to be
some i don't know quite how to do it but
right and that's why i i concur with on
your line 21 section roman numeral three
and to support the attorney general he
needs to be the prosecutor of this i
have nothing against the fines
i think that's reasonable it's just that
who's doing it it can't be the board by
itself some no i agree with somebody
else well i'm hoping that the courts
would step in on this well that's why
this that's why we don't want to go
forward with this right now we're
talking the same language i agree
um did you have anything
yes i really like to know hey can
how someone can recognize
a company
who doesn't have a license
well that's a felony if it's a company
doing it
but no no how we can recognize how yes
the person who has the stamp will
that would just be a matter of
investigation is he a freelancer working
for himself or is he part of a company
and that's what that would be well known
because i don't think
how do you find a surveyor
you either call a company you find
somebody that
your uncle harry recommended
i don't think that's a i don't think if
that's a practical problem
do you think so that you would know
whether it's an individual or whether
they're working for a company that that
would not be hard to determine
but in any case you've got to do you've
got the individual in the book
if it is
if we could get more terrific because if
it's a company it's a felony
um
not in what's called a not a natural
person
representative goalie do you have any
thoughts
one quick question um
let's go along with this we also were
given
paperwork with an amendment i believe
are we going to discuss that does
everyone have that i don't have that
what did the amendment say it was a
recommended amendment by senator the
senator
all right well let's
i'll be glad to look at that
all right i just want to make sure we go
away with this if they need this change
as well i haven't well yeah it's uh
okay
it's some suggested language from some
senator
oh okay this is a different way of doing
it
uh
yeah that's what i was saying
that's exact that's essentially what i
was saying
except that
um
the
rsa 310 a63 roman 1 and 2 do not specify
new hampshire specific
legal examination which i think is what
at least not in at least not as i
all right and that is the
but
are you going to insist on the
whole of that of roman 1 and 2 which is
the
so there are
national requirements for licensure
which
there are national requirements for
light licensure that all the applicants
have to pass and then there are local
requirements or state requirements
so when we say you your state has
similar
uh requirements and your license in that
state
you're welcome to come here and take our
exam to prove that you know what the
boundary laws in new hampshire are
and then we if you're successful then we
issue a license
we need we need that step
because you may work in a
public land state you may work in
colorado where they don't have
from the oak tree along the stone wall
to the
to the shore
they have all rectangular
and that person would not be
his experience would not be applicable
to new hampshire
so we do need the exam
i agree we need the exam
all right
not as well not as obvious to the naive
reader that the
proctored examination is
in two parts the the national type exam
and the
state specific
so that's already in the law unless
we're right
i think the better you're looking on
page two there i think the part that's
better is this one
um
which is
yeah that's that's a nice way of
doing it in the image
the correct section of law
so i'm good with that
so we don't need this we don't need the
uh the language or the language in the
uh bill it's going to we will replace it
with the amended the significance of
this different language yes i think
that's that meets my what the intent of
what i was trying to say
so i think it's
although i think you've got your in your
indents incorrect but that's a that's
something ols could fix
um
i'd like to recommend that we delete
lines 11 to 20
because
we don't support them
and we don't have the time to fix them
appropriately but i'd like to to get
some agreement on
line 21 where the board may investigate
but we should have an and
uh
what what would do we want to say they
report that to the attorney general
[Music]
okay i want to get our the gist of what
we want so we're
by i you said delete that i that's kind
of what i had been leading up to all
along with suggestion that we
asked them to
having heard us come back with something
maybe next year along with um beating
the drum for identification i want to
see that somewhere
and also
where the where would be most
appropriate to put into the
recording process
a check
madam chair yeah which line you just
said before
which like delete uh
lines 11 to 20 which is paragraph two
and add to paragraph three
the report the findings to the attorney
general okay because i i think that will
help a lot
in the prosecution
without
creating them as children doing we're
not judiciary but i would like to also
change b to a
i'm okay with that okay it's
you could have some very serious uh
that makes sense because judge can
always play they can always plead it
down but
can't go up that's not
okay
all right
so
um
what you you're talking about piercings
uh amen
pearson's
uh thought about these stamps has to be
you said somewhere along in the process
we don't want to do that but that would
be non-germane it's a different section
of law but it's it would certainly be
appropriate at the registry of deeds if
not the local level
to verify that the stamp is from a
licensed surveyor what i'm saying it may
not solve all the problems but it'll
stop the biggest cases where something
gets recorded incorrectly
again bill ducette from the board of
licensure there already is a statute on
the books uh that to record a plan it
shall be um stamped by a licensed land
surveyor
so for the registries that's taken care
of okay well thank you very much
okay
what i wanted was uh what i was talking
about
with that issue which bill ducette has
already handled is to indicate our
legislation for future legislation thank
you
such that
getting rid of the judge and jury aspect
okay appeal to superior court
indemnification they're the things i'm
looking for
okay
and uh
again i want to repeat what i said at
the beginning we want this to work we
want some we want something to happen
thank you
our subcommittee how do you feel about
that because we like to make a motion to
uh summarizing the things we've talked
about
class a okay i i'll summarize what i
think you said
first change on line nine class b to
class a misdemeanor
to
delete lines 11-20
which
is we don't think is correct online
online 21 which is roman 3 adds the end
of the investigation that the
they'll report the findings to the
attorney general for prosecution
and for
take the revised language
uh makes section 2 amend
rsa 310a69
rather than adding a new section
but we are agree with the 10 000 laws
11 to 20. okay
get reelected so you'll see it next year
i will try it
yeah
oh delete that
yeah oh just just a deletion
roman three
yes because you're covering it under
yes we don't suppose i think we're
supposed to
put a number for the penalty i'm sorry
we're supposed to put the number the
whole thing is out of the night
for now no oh
when they come back we're going to talk
about what okay the whole of this
paragraph
i i think we don't have the time to do
it properly so if you just take it out
oh okay
because
it's not something we're experts on and
we don't have the time to investigate it
thoroughly
so
let's deal with
yeah john they're they're in a lot
better shape come walking out the door
all right so the idea would be that we
would create an amendment that does
and
are we
is that all right with you
representative brian
o'brien's good
we knew that
okay so
um
would you like to move that
right well we don't have a number but
yes i will take we should
move the five move those five things yes
as the clerk has recorded right okay all
and
uh
representative brian would you like to
second
if you don't mind sticking around i'd
like to
make sure
you want me to go over to ols or do you
want to do it i don't care uh well
whoever it is we should i
assuming it is i i want to make sure i
have it exactly right so all right
unless you're
no i'm fine
all right another
hour oh
i have a lunch
bit of time
well if you have a bit of time
that's why you don't know okay
look i'm not trying to stick you with
you've listed the things there's nothing
further right there okay okay but i
you